je me suis tapé un petit doute km5 de
kayak au milieu du pertuis avec tous les
courants c'était moi en plus on est en
grandes marées pour que je puisse avoir
la lune pour m'orienter donc c'était
vraiment un petit moment de plaisir que
ça pour se taper un petit rappel de 25
30 mètres sur un fort en pleine nuit
c'était
magnifique ça c'est le genre d'aventuré
on adore aussi
alors ça déjà comment tu t'es peut-être
tu es fan de fort brillamment oui bah
c'est une émission qui a forgé l'enfance
de pas mal de personnes vont se dire hey
toi sans rien dire un personnage de fort
boyard non mais sans déconner vraiment
on verrait dans une cellule du rouergue
il passe crème un moment vous allez voir
le flibustier vous avez trois minutes
non mais c'est vrai c'est foot a
toujours aimé fort boyard et donc tu
t'es dit je vais m'introduire dans le
dans le fort et une fois l'intérieur
statut en plus voir les lieux cultes de
l'émission la vigie du père fouras la
salle du trésor et tu trouvais que tout
ça faisait un peu fou regarde il visite
du père fouras et franchement c'est
assez épatant à quoi je m'attendais
vraiment un truc qui fasse genre un met
de mètres de diamètre mais ça fait un
bon 3 m 3 mètres 50 1 c'est gros voyez
cette zone là où ils doivent apporter
les boyards
tu te dis bah c'est la pierre c'est une
petite estrade laver une raison
d'exister étouffe
pas de la pierre
alors que justement c'est parce qu'après
une langue qui ont dit que c'est chez
quoique estia je suis coach et enfin
rien ne vas te dérange tant mois sans
moi parce qu'on les a réprimés banon
mais excusez moi je reste comprend que
la société porte est plein vous avez
pris des risques énormes vous pouvez
faire des émules et ça c'est hyper
dangereux parce que si lui est tombé
apparemment j'ai compris que en fait il
ya ça capte pas vous n'auriez même pas
pu appeler pour qu'on vienne vous vous
sauver donc gros gros gros risques tout
ça pour nous dire que c'est du carton
pâte on s'en doutait un peu quand même
pas me suis énervé télé hier soir j'ai
pas compris delphine moi c'est super
cool n'importe qui peut y aller mais
alors monsieur le flibustier maintenant
vous allez aller chez delphine vous
allez rentrer un jour où elle sera pas
là vous allez par donation de bain et
vous aller filmer chez elle et bien vous
allez rentrer chez nous vous allez
rentrer chez eux
mais c'est pas ça tu rentres chez toi tu
vas te retrouver avec sa mère elle tu
vas tu as fait ressortir ses parfums
convient là dedans je n'aime pas
maintenant c'est bon alors ça ma
connaissance ne mettez pas dans monument
historique en fait à
l'époque où j'ai visité 4
non mais c'est ce que je n'avais pas le
droit de rentrer là dedans on va pas
jouer avec les mots mais ça va
franchement faut arrêter de prendre la
tête il a fait son kiff ça y est je suis
dit 'mon imaginent demain un gabin suit
l'exemple de ce mois et le gamin n'est
pas aussi habile que monsieur bré chute
des 20 mètres et se blesse voire pire
non mais sérieusement blessé mais
avec des si on mettrait des couilles en
bouteille
gestion mettrait paris en bouteille mais
en fait vous êtes je pense que c'est
bien qu'il n'ait qu'ils aient porté par
contre vous parce que vous n'aurez
qu'une table sur la sur le doigt et un
rappel à la loi et c'est pas très grave
mais pour marquer le coup et pour
expliquer son
départ de la production ils sont
complètement hypocrite sur ce coup là
ils en ont rien à [ __ ] de 6 bien su
arrêter c'est que ça les soul qu'on ait
dit à regarder c'est du buzz
sur la région et franchement aller voir
la vidéo est dure 30 minutes c'est
encore mieux qu'une émission de télé si
ça c'était sur france 5 qui m'ont dit
que c'est du génie et c'est franchement
super bien fait est super intéressant
donc franchement bravo messieurs les
nations en fait s'il ya une petite
nuance que la production ne prend pas en
compte c'est que déjà il ya des choses
beaucoup plus délirante que ça qu'ils
ont pas besoin de matériel sur youtube
des gens qu'ils suspendaient des grues
des choses comme ça c'est tout des
choses qui sont réalisés par des
professionnels est en fait déjà ce que
j'ai fait c'est quelque chose que j'ai
fait avec beaucoup de préparation aussi
bien matérielles que compétences et ce
n'est pas quelque chose qui est faisable
par tout le monde et déjà il faut déjà
avoir le matériel pour pouvoir le faire
et ne serait ce que pour approcher le
fort en kayak c'est une préparation bien
sûr le perthus et énormément de cours on
ne peut pas dire que c'est comme ça
qu'on peut pas rassuré mais la pression
pasqua ne pas avoir demandé une
autorisation
j'ai essayé je le dis au moment de la
conclusion en fait à l'époque j'avais
deux mille abonnés maintenant j'en ai un
peu plus parce que ces bordels
voit la bombe à patienter on est
créateur le but c'est toujours de faire
durant autour des sens comme un gros
voulait faire du buzz c'est à ça que
celui-là pas du tout alors faire du buzz
était revenu avec avec des têtes comme
ça
même des gros créateurs comme le joueur
du grenier qui a plusieurs millions
d'abonnés on lui a refusé une
autorisation de tournage permet je vais
tenir jusqu'aux te direct quelqu'un qui
guardian alfort et coiffes allemand il
m'a dit mais un acteur le gardien du
fort et seniors et jean-louis dit non
j'ai eu un contact avec quelques amis à
quatre pattes
agents de la dea bien énorme alors je
vais te dire je vais te dire deux mots
le fond de ma pensée je vous dire ça
c'est des vieilles institutions fort
boyard et comme je veux raconter une
anecdote mes options miss france on
devait avoir diane l'air avec sylvie
tellier la marque mais redit mardi ils
ont dit non non on veut pas que diane
mer soit aux côtés de sylvie tellier
parce que après oui on va dire qu'elle
prend parti pour sylvie tellier qu'après
l'aiment pas si denis fabre donc elle
vient pas voilà donc ce que vous dire
c'est la même société je vous dis race
alexia laroche-joubert qu'on aime bien
elle vient souvent ici mais c'est vrai
que alexia elle à l'ancienne alexia
c'est la gardienne du temple et céret
qu'alexia c'est des vieux voilà cesser
ces vieux cesser ses fils et d'abyei
télévision la nord est et ce qu'elle
fait ce qu'elle peut et sait très bien
ce qu'elle veut c'est de la vieille télé
etc des vieux cd des livres du réflexe
donc ils ont vu un gars qui voulait
venir ils ont dit manon fait comme
d'habitude et bon bah on va on va
attaquer mais en fait certainement rien
à [ __ ] que ce soit pour le protéger
dans le fort on croit aux caisses c'est
juste parce que ils veulent marquer le
coup et dire voilà comme ça ou alors
moins on arrêtait ont attaqué plus
personne aux pays-bas du décès des vieux
mécanismes c'est comme avec miss france
diane l'air et l'eau très bien pu venir
avec sophie et sylvie tellier mais non
parce qu'apprendre à coire calais voilà
c'est un peu des viewers et c'est comme
ça si vous voulez je vous dise ces dix
personnes c'est des personnes qui sont
là depuis 40 ans la télévision et qui
n'ont pas les réflexes voilà au
d'aujourd'hui c'est tout mais là où ils
sont à côté de la plaque c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas compris que ce genre de vidéos
ça sert les missions bien tu as fait des
jeunes qui regardent l'émission ils
découvrent fort boyard s'ils avaient
tagué le fort s'il avait détruites fort
ok pas de problème mais là il fait
découvrir les coulisses du fort oui
c'est beau comme c'est comme quand koh
lanta koh lanta ça fait parler de
l'émission ça entretient la marque et
franchement ils ont tout à gagner avec
ça ils ont aucune raison de l'attaqué
c'est
dans une can de buzz et quelle sera la
prochaine étape comme dit daniel quelle
sera la prochaine étape à ce que vous
allez aller chez cyril
mais c'est pas du
foot et bien sûr jean cocteau du jeu
d'enfouir venir chez moi déjà en fait
ils n'ont
actuel de l'urbex est un peu fauche pour
moi parce que actuellement tout le monde
fait des lieux abandonnés et des choses
comme ça déjà c'est que le sommet de
l'iceberg
et dans la pratique de base de l'urbex
les domiciles ça n'en fait pas partie
même que les gens qui vont sur tata
jeanine qui est morte il ya dix ans et
que personne n'a récupéré la baraque
parce que les héritiers se foutent sur
la gueule depuis dix ans c'est quoi si
ça s'était bien passé de bayeux risque
c'est du voyeurisme
ses biens jeanine voilà l'image que je
veux dire et vanille alors la bataille
des explications oui oui tout à fait non
mais quand même un l'urbex et c'est pour
ça daniel c'est pas dans les
appartements c'est visiter les lieux
construits et abandonner
un pote et une toiture en tôle et sûrs
en donnant les noms mais c'est vrai
améliorant dans les critères tu été
déconstruite abandonné donc voilà votre
showroom et que
tu arrives par ses propres moyens tu
fais des photos ou des vidéos est une
touche rien leur bec c'est vraiment une
voiture doit réembaucher on revient
effectivement
le problème c'est que en termes de
sécurité tu t'es quand même appuyé à de
la roche et à des trucs métalliques ils
sont clairement friable et voilà et tu
aurais pu effectivement te tuer et c'est
ça le problème en terme d'assurance ce
qui pourrait après ça mais là tu veux
quand même responsable et aussi la
deuxième chose c'est que tu es quand
même rentrer dans le dans les bureaux de
production où il y avait quand même des
documents officiels et confidentiel de
cela c'est un peu gênant officiel audi
c'est bon c'est moi faudrait les payer
parfois
il ya quelque chose de
savoir combien mesure passe partout au
sens où le rsa
6000 enfants et aînés arrêtez vous êtes
united vous êtes tous des lieux les gens
me disent à leur siège c'est pas une
question de date annoncée comme alexia
laroche joubert de elle pense à eux ces
mécanismes sont des mécanismes de dieu
ces missions sont des émissions de jeux
les fondateurs sont des amateurs de
vieux non mais c'est vrai c'est à dire
lnv pas avec son temps on peut être âgés
et vivre avec son temps non mais sans
déconner c'est vrai moi c'est pas une
question de jeunisme sur un camion de
josé houde et review pas mieux taire
compote vieux et livrets qui sont en eux
ils sont et ils sont sur les vieux
mécanismes se plaide daniel un shérif
qu'est ce que tu as heard mais non mais
parce que ça me hérisse le poil pourquoi
mais parce que là vous êtes en train de
dire il faut vivre avec son temps donc
le temps modernes c'est ça c'est pas du
tout berne ap buenos aires on va pas la
vérité aussi bien rien fait de mal il a
pas pissé dans fort boyard
sur mes épaules et j'aurais dû lui dire
moi si j'avais été au sort était
beaucoup plus intéressant lui dire voilà
écouter fallait pas le faire on va on
lui passe un coup de fil lui dit voilà
mareval fer tordus ou bien est ce qu'il
aurait dû faire c'était le prof sur une
forme d'exemplarité
l'invité avant mais le prendre mais il
se dit donc pas le besoin ils ont 200
ans les gars et son curieux que le père
foire est une belle et très triste
d'entendre valérie et daniel et même
béatrice défendent ce c'est pas surtout
bertrand surtout béatrice et béatrice
oui les deux autres j'en attendais pas
grand-chose rémois
face à une journaliste y que nos
performances d'un youtube heures
franchement non mais il faut vivre ce
qu'il a fait c'est bien il a pris
quelques risques mais il est équipé et
il fait une émission formidable qui
dépoussière le fort et vous là vous êtes
là
c'est vrai qu'on va clore le débat là
dessus et les médias juste mettre les
pieds dans le plat par rapport au bureau
comme ça parce qu'en fait les bureaux de
la production globalement toutes les
pièces techniques étaient verrouillées
sauf que un bureau le projet le fameux
bureau de la production était ouvert
avec l'armoire avec toutes les clés non
à libre disposition non en fait pour
parfaire ma vidéo j'ai juste eu à
rentrer dans le fort non à aller au
bureau et en servir pour une emporte non
donc il ya comme un problème non mais
c'est ça qu'on fait c'est énorme lave
qui va nourrir donc avait toutes les
clefs et en l'occurrence ça c'est
quelque chose que j'ai été privé oui
mais non mais non mais non mais non
mariés mais neymar est peut-être
défendre l'indéfendable parce que c'est
quelque chose qui pouvait mettre part
mais c'est vrai production mais la mc
des yeux var est un peu tu travailleras
jamais qu'alexia laroche-joubert que tu
t'en fous c'est vrai de succès non elle
a [ __ ] ça va t'inquiète pas d'abord il
ya une dot d'intrusion dans le forez a
été nombreuse ça c'est sûr pas le seul
bon tout le monde n'a pas filmé en
revanche il est vrai que la prod est
obligé de porter plainte justement à
cause de ça pour se protéger les
yeux et j'ai invité il aurait dû inviter
ses comptes et j'en remercie
nino non j'avais en moi pour le coup
j'ai fait des vidéos sur youtube et
quand tu es un petit créateurs au début
il ya aucune porte s'est ouverte nulle
part et on va pas se mentir 90% des
tournages youtube se font sans aucune
autorisation sans demander rien à
personne on va voir un vrai film un
danger mais pendant les stages suis
d'accord mais en tout cas je pense que
si il avait demandé au fort personnes
lui auraient prêté une oreille tu vois
et maintenant par contre qu'il a fait ça
c'est là qu'il va devenir intéressant
pour lyon c'est un petit peu dommage
mais c'est comme ça que ça a bien
fonctionné